hyah reject nation I'm never gonna do
that well we're doing the pirate thing
is that what we're doing
no I was doing a penny wise from the og
Tim Curry not the we're just doing
accents British accent it out tonight
fantastic fantastic plastic dad Jess
anyway that's a good accent wow I'm so
sorry I messed that up in the beginning
because he was you were doing a British
Court and I think he was going somewhere
with it and I interrupted it with my
idiocy welcome to this idiot and oh yeah
my name is tara harrison cuz you forgot
to introduce me before cuz it's all
about you always has been about you it's
never about me we're gonna watch the
honest trailer today for ya I told her
to say that to make sure it is in my top
five twenty seven I don't know what my
other ones are but it would be in my top
five well let's see if honest trailers
can make fun of it well enough John
Bailey TurboTax no we do those two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one direction
Oh the exact same way
they kid go off on their own notice
something out of the ordinary
until the monster pops out and get your
required dose of a pop culture yeah New
Kids on the Block bullets that terrible
Street Fighter game that time in school
[Music]
[Laughter]
that managed to out Greek in curry and
wisely planet aborting adult stuff that
no one remembers to this equal plus make
some radical departures from the
original book digi the fifties era that
preteen gangbang scene and the
appearance of Maturin the god turtle who
teaches building and perform the magic
ritual a chewed you guys made that one
odd no really
oh thanks is it cut but the same day I
don't want to see that so enjoy a
horrifying truth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
they wanted to give us one more book
warms my favor I thought about that
whole lethal weapon to thing that they
closed this up with the lethal weapon
- and Batman they come out at different
times doesn't get out in September we
just love our nostalgia though that's
the thing about it man when they're
talking about the scary stuff it did hit
me that even though I really did enjoy
the hell out of this movie I liked it a
lot I never think of any of the scary
moments there's nothing that's scary to
me I mean did they scare you
they're kind of like cliche like slow
walking at Billy Bob you know like maybe
like one or two where I did jump but I'm
also like I did a little bit terrified
of clowns the only reason that I don't
think I was super super scared in the
movie cuz I would have been because I
watch
trailer a bunch and I wanted to over
expose myself to it like James Franco oh
no I'm not doing it right hold on I
can't do the okay nevermind like James
I'm not feeling it I'm not feeling I
can't do it but it didn't work I can't
do the bit didn't work louis c.k would
have been funnier he's the one who
overexposed all the time
elisee asks first and that was a great
point about what they did with though
the black kid making him kind of like
the Winston and ghostbusters because
he's such an important part in the book
I mean I saw the TV movie and he's the
kid who knows all the information and
said we gave it to the kid chunk
oh gee Choji Charlie gave it's Chucky
mom character yeah well I would have
made him the bookworm I would have made
him the lead I would have cast all them
Oh one white guy you are too white
where's their diversity and chance and
our movies are still white a little TV
is ethnic now yes TV but also casting
for film you want to go through an agent
you're white they're like mule or on the
you're an eighties child right ELISA yes
you're born 1975 yeah yeah chunk I'm 45
years old you might be sensitive about
your age I'm sensitive about my weight
and I think I'm more sensitive wait
think I need like a little just if I
lifted right here right yeah lip
injecting a little and you still like
wow she looks young now like just like a
little maybe like a maybe like that you
look like you're in your 20s Terra right
but then I'll look like am 18 yeah great
lizard face but do you have a lot of
nostalgia when you see all this stuff
yes that's why I became obsessed with
stranger things and that's why this is
probably in my top
five I love all of these always all the
time every time I have a birthday party
I want to have it themed the 80s I don't
choose the 90s and I mostly grew up in
the 90s I'm like no let's take back to
the 80s you know I mean like
off-the-shoulder me on getting naked
right up here fluffy Oh
Tati oh there it's so sorry yeah I was
just trying to be real in the moment
show you what I was talking about
because I forgot what that's what a
tease child voice yeah that's what you
mean the most interesting also yeah well
weird most interesting they're kind of
the same thing right I mean I've never
learned manners and etiquette see forget
about it rebels that's why you're like I
do appreciate the 80s quite a lot do you
have any other questions breathing you
do British accent because that's me
having mad because nobody in the
eighties and he frickin manners
apparently I'm sorry I'm sorry do you I
I won't talk anymore you only ask me
questions and then I'll properly answer
them that'll be a lot of fun I snipped I
I snipped in slipped into cook thing
there for a second I was moving and
grooving here with the eighty stop until
he got all uh cuz I know you're his
precious little Mike here okay I'm just
saying I love the 80s give me all the
eighties things just let me say one
thing Gregory I know you want me to zip
it yeah just leave I'm going to talk to
them they love this you guys remember
the red rope that was like two feet long
they dont sell it anymore but they sold
it in the 80s and early 90s it was so
long that you could like jump rope with
it but then you would take the cover at
the plastic cover off it was like so
long and then you would eat it that's
the end of my story you can come back
now
subscribe you the real rejects why not
you should actually just check out Tara
Erickson's channel this I'm not in this
video today about you really don't